the only record of Donald Trump's health
that we've seen that anyone seen is a
glowing letter from his physician of 30
years dr. Harold Bornstein there's a
picture of dr. Bornstein folks that's a
real photo uh dr. Bornstein he said in
the letter mr. Trump would be quote
unequivocally the healthiest individual
ever elected to the presidency he also
called Trump's lab results astonishingly
excellent well it turns out that the
doctor wrote the letter in five minutes
while mr. Trump's limo waited outside
his office I'm not making that up either
so I've asked dr. Bornstein to show to
join us via satellite and maybe explain
his practices please welcome from New
York City
dr. Harold Bornstein hello dr. Boyce I
counted right hi how you doing I'm doing
fine dr. Bornstein is this letter you
wrote about Donald Trump's health
accurate well it's hard to say what's
accurate in my profession medical
science isn't an exact science no it is
actually one of the most exact of all
the sciences no Konya one doctor may say
mr. Trump is a seven-year-old man who's
overweight has high cholesterol and
suffers from hypertension and I might
say this is the healthiest man alive he
should be running our country
okay all right based on the amount of
time it took you to write your letter
I'm really curious about how you examine
your patients what's your met well it is
a very rigorous examination process
first I open the window and stick my
head out then I carefully scan the
street from my patients limousine and
then I'll ask myself how long is that
limo is it shiny does it have a sunroof
then based on the quality of that limo
I'll make a rough estimate as to the
health of the limousines passenger wait
okay you're saying that's your entire
examination process whoa whoa whoa whoa
just wait a second hear me out
yeah that's it well sir that is very
very unprofessional you know I don't
really appreciate your negativity okay I
am a doctor who went to the University
of great okay
I graduated magna [ __ ] great job okay
University of great yes it's one of the
top three medical schools at the Port
Authority every night all right okay
okay okay Conan I gotta go I think I
know what that is the Koch brothers are
flying by in a blimp I got to give them
their physical you look great guys all
right thank you very much for real
doctor from really not a musty
you